we are learning about the fate of an
unprecedented number of migrant children
caught up in the crisis on the southern
border CBS News has discovered there are
more than 10,000 unaccompanied children
in the care of the federal government's
office of refugee resettlement Manuel
Bojorquez spoke exclusively with the
agency's director and joins us from
Washington so Manny many of these
children could stay in federal custody
for their entire childhoods right up
till they're 18 right that's correct and
in fact the director of the Office of
refugee resettlement told us well over
4,000 of the more than 10,000 children
in the agency's care are at risk of
remaining in custody long term we also
got an exclusive look inside one Center
in Texas were some of the youngest
migrants are housed
we are the first Network news
organization allowed to freely walk the
halls of the San Benito facility about
20 minutes outside of Brownsville Texas
the shelter houses the youngest of
unaccompanied minors children who showed
up by themselves at the border or were
separated from relatives because they
are minors for their privacy the office
of refugee resettlement or Orr requested
we use their cameras so they could blur
out their faces so they have 96 beds at
this facility and currently they have 79
mostly women staying at this facility
with the exception of a few baby boys
that are here with their mothers lakyn
was that that's a that's a that's a
small baby there's one yes so quantal
one month old yes Wow oh our our
director Jonathan Hayes gave us a tour
last month yes we have all you know all
ages here from from 0 up to 17 we even
saw a 2 year old boy from Brazil who is
in this country alone oh are ours says
its goal is to give the children as safe
and normal as stay as possible until
they can be released to a vetted
relative or sponsor but CBS News has
learned more than 4,000 of those migrant
children at our
168 shelters in 23 states could be held
long-term they have no identifiable
sponsors and they are labeled category
for children the highest designation how
long possibly are these children in your
custody until they turn 18 you know
conceivably someone could come into our
care at you know 15 years old and not
have an identifiable sponsor in the
United States and remain with us for a
few years it's already happening we
recently learned of one case of a child
in custody going on for years immigrant
advocates believe that violates the
Flores agreement which mandates children
be released as quickly as possible they
argue some of the administration's
policies even ice arrests recently
publicized by the president could be
discouraging undocumented relatives from
coming forward Bob Kerry was Orr
director under the Obama administration
they're fearful and the children are
fearful that their parents will be
harmed or their answer uncle's will be
or that other people on the household
will be targeted and I think that's a
legitimate fear and this is the intake
office back at the San Benito shelter
program director Melissa Aguilar says
caseworkers try their best to place a
child before their 18th birthday when
they are transferred to ice custody for
adults and can be deported there's
challenges definitely with contacting
sponsors I'm getting them to submit all
the paperwork because as you can see we
wouldn't just let anybody pick up a
child it's a challenging process at
times three former Orr officials who
spoke with CBS News say the number of
those category four children has risen
dramatically over the last few years in
what they describe as an alarming rate
the director of our our Jonathan Hayes
is scheduled to speak before a House
panel today about the safety of
immigrant children across all the
agencies shelters Tony
incredible reporting Manny thank you
very much important to realize that
these are facilities that are not
designed for long term care and they are
nearing capacity exactly what thousand
children and the more you hear about it
just to hear them referred to as
category for children is just so
upsetting and disturbing to me and to
know that many of them may never be
reunited with their parents it's not
breaking